thank you all so much for joining us
today and for joining us here in our
live Q&A room and spending time with us
this Wednesday special thank you to
Garrett for the awesome
demo and as a reminder if you want to
ask any questions here in the Q&A you
can do so anonymously using the same uh
slid link I shared before I'm going to
show it on the screen here as
well at
P.D demo questions so you can use that
to ask any questions anonymously or you
can just put them straight into the
YouTube chat here um I usually save this
for the end but I think it's worth
saying here with everybody as well if
you do want to end up doing a trial of
posit workbench or connect which you saw
today in Garrett's demo you can also use
the link I'll show on the screen here to
chat with our team and receive an
evaluation environment I'm sure they'd
love to chat more about your team's use
case um but thanks again for joining us
we have a few special guests joining
here alongside Garrett as well so I'd
love to have us all introduce ourselves
and maybe share a fun fact of where is
your favorite vacation
spot and let's see I'll go in order here
Ryan do you want to go first yeah sure
um hey everybody I'm Ryan so I've been
on a few of these demos now we've been
doing since gosh I feel like it's been
like almost a year now but it's great to
see so many folks joining these sessions
so I'm a data science adviser here at
posit and I guess my favorite vacation
spot is probably Maine I had a great
grandmother that lived in Maine and I
loved going up there it's been a little
while but I love the outdoors and Main's
are pretty
awesome Garrett wantan to go
next well hi everybody thank you for
attending my webinar um my name is
Garrett I work in developer relations at
deposit and I'm a recent Resident of the
Tampa Bay area so I like to go back
there to visit friends but also like
clearw beach is just excellent so that's
my favorite vacation
spot nice
Garrick hi I'm Garrick H I'm a developer
on the shiny team at posit and I think
my favorite vacation spot would be
somewhere in the mountains with a river
that uh I could go whitewater rafting
on awesome and
Carson hi yeah I'm Carson uh also an
engineer on the shiny team and my
favorite vacation spot would have to be
Southern California uh probably
particularly
um uh near San San Diego area love to
golf so love to love to golf in that
area and um
yeah awesome and I didn't introduce
myself but I'm Dempsey I lead customer
marketing here at pit and it's hard for
me to pick favorites but I think my
favorite spot would be Block Island
Rhode Island which is a little island I
like to go to every
summer um okay bear with us here in our
intros I also just wanted to add that it
is also Garrett's birthday today so
maybe we can embarrass ourselves with
singing happy birthday to garrot and
we'll and you all can join us here okay
happy birthday to
youday to
youy birthday dear
G happy happy birthday to you oh that
was
awful we're all at slightly different um
Wi-Fi speeds too I think that really
added to it okay well thank you all for
submitting the questions beforehand too
so I want to make sure I cover some of
those that were in the demo and then
I'll jump into the ones
here um but one of the first questions I
saw was does bs lib work with shiny
dashboard and I think Carson wanted to
answer this one sure I can take this um
no it does not work with shiny
dashboard uh but the good news to that
is we view BS lib at being at a stage
now where we view it as suers seeding uh
shiny dashboard so a lot of the
components that you use in shiny
dashboard you'll find modern
replacements for NBS lib so we have
things like cards and sidebar layouts
um and also things you won't find like
tool tips and popovers that will add
some um really nice additional
functionality um to your dashboards uh
and then of course you get all like sort
of the rich theming uh infrastructure
that comes with blib as well um so but
you know technically speaking there's
some there was just some challenges with
updating shiny dashboard from you know
it uses this framework called admin LTE
which was built on bootstrap 3 so
bringing up both of those dependencies
to Modern versions there was just kind
of some technical complexity with that
where we decided to kind of go in a
different direction
we decided that we would actually kind
of build out these components and b aib
instead of depending on a framework that
was struggling to keep uh up to speed
with with modern
practices um so I know there is a few
things uh probably the biggest thing is
sidebar navigation I think I've seen at
least one question about this uh where
we don't have an answer for you know a
shiny dashboard you can have kind of
like links that that navigate to
different sections of content uh in your
dashboard and we don't have a great
answer for that in BS lib at the moment
um but is probably you know at the top
of our priority list for for new UI work
coming
previously thank you I see a bunch of
questions coming in here on YouTube and
I'll go jump to the first one I see
Oliver asked thanks for the great talk
do you know if BS lib layout columns
would allow me to add cards dynamically
depending on the user
inputs well I could take a stab at this
um first of all I I'll say I'm a user of
these packages and then I'm really glad
that grick and Carson are here because
they're developers and they could
correct me if I'm wrong but if you think
of I don't know if you have previous
experience with shiny but if you create
UI dynamically
what you can do is shiny and then maybe
use fluid rows and columns to place that
in your app or create a chunk of input
that uses those the same thing happens
with layout columns so I think the
answer is yes although I haven't tried
it
yet I see Garrick smiling so yeah I'll
go on record and say that was spot on
that uh the best way to do that is to
use Dynamic UI uh bring your layout
columns into the Server create your
cards there and then um and that way you
can have Dynamic number of
cards awesome okay another question from
YouTube is Will BS lip have any
conflicts with shiny dashboard or shiny
widgets I know we touched on shiny
dashboard would you want to comment on
on that too yeah I'm kind of vaguely
aware that
um I mean this was kind of you know
entangled with that technical problem of
bringing shiny Dash for up to a modern
version of bootstrap is if we are to do
that we are kind of asking the greater
ecosystem of shiny packages to move
along with us to
moving you know all the code that
they've written that is targeting a
certain version of bootstrap like if we
just update the dependencies of these
kind of core packages then we're kind of
asking the Greater Community to to come
along that ride uh with us so I know I'm
sort of vaguely aware that there are
some sry can you hear me okay my
headphones just yeah okay yep I can hear
you yeah so I know there's vaguely some
issues with shiny widgets working with
bootstrap five um and if you're using BS
lib components like cards and sidebar
layouts like our our modern answers for
dashboarding um um they're going to
require you to use bootstrap 5
so yes there there might be some issues
with using certain widgets from shiny
widgets inside of a BS lib dashboard
that is using bootstrap five um but
hopefully that situation continues to
improve and you know the maintainer of
shiny widgets will continue to make
their stuff more compatible with with
modern versions of bootstrap
thank you another question from a bit
earlier was what resources would you
recommend to read Around BS lib and
other aspects of styling and
shiny do you want to take this one
Garrick sure um so BSB has a a homepage
um if you search the web for BS you can
find the documentation homepage and uh
we have a number of articles there
including uh several getting started
articles some of them are around theming
um they give you a good place to start
if you're wanting to learn how to theme
your apps with BSB and there's also
another article that if you're
interested in learning more about how to
create dashboards with BS lib uh under
getting started there's a an article
called shiny dashboards and it's a great
place to start to get familiar with the
sort of dashboard layouts and components
uh that BS can provide
can I just second that because that's
how I've learned USS lib and and that
website is so thorough like it's it's
really well done it's surpasses what you
might think of as documentation it's
really like a learning
portal thank you um another question
over from YouTube was are the packages
presented in this session also
compatible with shiny for
python
who wants to take
it and I I don't know 100% of the
packages that were presented um but I
guess I'll say there's a probably a
decent chunk of the stuff that you've
seen uh that is available in chiny for
python so you know we've been talking
about bs lib and kind of the two big
main features of BS lib is the custom
theming aspect and the suite of
components uh that allow you to like
build nice looking
dashboards definitely that Suite of
components um you'll find the same you
you know you'll find layout columns
you'll find cards you'll find layout
sidebar um you'll find all of these
things in shiny for python currently at
the moment we don't have as Rich Uh
custom theming abilities in shiny for
python um but that is certainly higher
up on our priority list for for giving
you an experience that is close to uh
the experience that you get with BSL
with custom theming that doesn't mean
you can't do custom theming uh in shiny
for python it's just a little bit
different of an approach that's maybe a
little bit harder to get started with um
and and more technically difficult uh
but it's certainly possible if if you
have the um the drive for figuring out
how to do it it's uh there's nothing
preventing you from writing
CSS just put it that
way this isn't necessarily A a question
but I saw a lot of excitement the past
two days about shiny Express and was
just wondering if either of you from the
shiny team um could could share a little
bit about
that
uh yeah I I guess I'll keep going
um so shiny Express is essentially like
a a a new syntax mode for writing shiny
apps in
Python um so it allows you to
essentially intermingle UI and server
code uh so instead of having a separate
UI object and a separate server
function um you get to essentially uh
mix the two which allows you to write
more succinct um shiny code where you
can
essentially um you know write like a
render function directly in a script and
then that effectively transforms itself
into you know an output container with a
server render function
um so shiny Express itself is built on
you know shiny what we're calling shiny
core which is you know the the way that
you're used to writing shiny apps in R
essentially um and that way of writing
shiny apps is not going anywhere we kind
of view that
as um you know the way that you're going
to want to write shiny apps that uh on a
project where you really value long-term
maintainability and flexibility
um because Express like it says in the
name does take some shortcuts to make it
easier to learn and write shiny apps but
it's going to be a little bit more
restrictive in what you're able to do
with it so we're hoping like it's going
to be a nice on-ramp for people like
it's a lot quicker to get started even
development wise it's really nice to you
know type less to create uh an
example um but again for more serious
projects where where you're going to
want to put this thing in production and
test it and work on a team of people
potentially to to to develop this app
and write good modular code uh the
classic way of sh writing shiny apps is
is still we we think best in that kind
of context
so thank you and shiny Express is solely
for python at the moment right it is
solely for python
um you uh it's not like we couldn't
bring this to r as well but one one
thing um to also worth pointing out here
about Shai Express and the possibility
of bringing it to R is that we already
have something that feels pretty close
to shiny Express with um our markdown
documents with runtime shiny mode if you
look at shiny Express apps they're
they're quite similar to that same style
of you you know with your rmd document
with runtime shiny you can essentially
just like inline a render plot statement
and then it
renders renders a plot there that's
fully
interactive that's a it's a very
similar uh kind of concept and style for
shiny Express um
so you um another question asked over on
slido was can you remind us of the
manual pointand click package to create
shiny apps um and can this be integrated
with what was shown
today this is shameful I don't remember
the name of the package because I don't
use it it is out there I don't know
Garrick or Carson do you know I think
this is referring to the shiny UI
editor um possibly so that would be um
uh let's see it's a a package also a vs
code
extension um you can search for shiny UI
editor and uh it's a way to to basically
pick out components kind of drag them
into your into your app and kind of get
the skeleton of a UI for your shiny app
um and to build that really quickly so
I'd recommend looking at that the other
the other thing that Garrett demoed
today was the uh the
themer or the theme preview so BS lib BS
theme preview uh you can use that um you
can even um I'm forgetting the exact
function but you can you can use a
similar function to run the theme
preview for your own app kind of inject
the the dynamic theming into your app
which is what we saw today
so thank you I'm trying to grab the
links as they're mentioned but I just
want to make sure I'm sharing the right
ones there in in the
chat uh let me jump back over to YouTube
chat okay
okay so I saw a few questions that
touched on Cordo and how BS lib works
with
Cordo um this specific one is are BS lib
and thematic useful for creating Cordo
presentations with reveal
JS I'll take this one um one of the
things I'm really excited about with BSB
is that um learning when when you're
learning bsli a lot of the skills that
you learn are ultimately transferable to
a lot of different places in the shiny
ecosystem and uh this is a this is a
good highlight of one of those ways so
as you're learning how to use BS lib to
theme to theme bootstrap in particular
um cardo uses a very similar setup to
them to to theme uh presentation slides
HTML documents in general um which is
all kind of based around using the
variables that bootstrap provides and a
um an a package called SAS which is
basically commandline tool for rendering
CSS um what it does is it lets you
customize CSS uh with things like your
own colors or your own fonts or you know
lots of different things there's lots of
different ways that you can change the
theme uh you know how bootstrap looks
and the way that you do it with BS is
very very similar to how you um approach
that problem with quo also similar to
how you approach it with theming um our
markdown document ments um and and a
number of other
things yeah and the one small thing I'll
add about thematic is the
automatic detection of colors and fonts
might not work um
in um reveal JS
presentations um and actually with Corto
I'm pretty sure there's only like the
automatic detection stuff only really
works in our markdown I don't think it
works currently at all with quto but um
it still gives you
highlevel parameters for saying you know
here's a background color here's a
foreground color and here is a font and
here's an accent color um so it still
simplifies and distills like these kind
of main color and font ideas and
translates that to your R plots um
you'll just have to do a little bit of
work of you know bringing in those
colors and fonts into thematic as
well thank you um I just wanted to add
I'm always looking for fun ways to bring
the the community and customers together
to learn new things and so
mid-February I have this H small group
chat I'm hosting with Amil on the Cordo
team to talk specifically about custom
branding your Cordo dos I don't really
have like a link to sign up right now
but I'm just going to put my email email
in the chat too so if anybody's
interested in that just send me a quick
email and let me
know uh let's see okay another question
was will changing the changing themes
and colors for a shiny Flex dashboard
work the same way as
demonstrated or is that an our markdown
fle is that's Flex
dashboard
yeah so Flex dashboard is uh based on
our markdown uh it's a way of creating
dashboards using our markdown it's sort
of now it's the the predecessor to cardo
dashboards um BSB lets you customize the
theme of our markdown documents the
Syntax for doing that is a little bit
different from what we saw today where
you um have to make those changes in uh
the yaml front matter of the document
rather than in the code um
and but beyond that it's a it's a pretty
similar process in terms of figuring out
which parts of the theme you want to
change and uh and basically setting
those variables and values um that's
also covered in the BSB uh documentation
page so you can you can find some
information about styling and theming
our markdown documents
there okay thank you and I know
everybody can't just hang out with us
all day long here so I'm going everybody
listening in included um so I'm just
going to go to maybe two more questions
but one I saw over on slido was can you
talk about issues related to shiny apps
with different screen widths this app is
only Built to be shown on full screen is
there any way to be more
flexible and Garrett I think you
commented on that in the demo too maybe
about how it adjusts
to changing sizes yeah now now I'm going
to say something stupid in front of
Garrick and Carson but I I can see
there's a lot of built-in Behavior to
adjust for that sort of thing and I I
know that there's a lot of control to
take it further that I don't know how to
use and hav't explored so maybe maybe I
could pun here to to one of the
engineers I'd say that a lot of it is is
built around looking or trying our best
to look good at uh all different screen
sizes um one of the things that I
noticed in this one was that we were uh
in this app we were zooming in quite a
bit to try to make sure that everything
was readable for the video and I think
the experience if you are developing
locally or you were actually looking at
the app on your on your desktop would be
a little bit different um we also in the
last year introduced an idea of
fillability this a kind of a slightly
Advanced concept but but we have some
nice articles on the BS Li page that um
that can help with that the general idea
is that in especially in dashboards you
have these UI components or you have
plots where they really want to take up
like the full height and width of the
cell that they're in so you kind of want
to have a plot that that fills up the
entire card rather than um being just a
fixed size and um and often playing with
the settings for whether something is
fillable as in it fills its container um
you can get to different different
layouts um that uh it depends a lot on
the type of thing that you're you're
trying to put into your
dashboard maybe one more just quick
question um does thematic work well with
plotly it's funny we were just talking
about this in private before before the
chat here but um
partially yes um if you're using
ggplotly then
um plotly does a little bit of extra
work to you know make sure that like the
result that you would get with ggplot 2
in thematic is going to be the same as
what you'll get with
ggplotly in plotly but if you're using
the like core plotly API uh like if
you're not using ggplot 2 at all
then um thematic like the plotly graph
will not respect whatever you're doing
with
thematic
um and it would be nice
to I don't know if the answer is for
plotly to respect thematic but um I
think plotly could certainly do a little
bit more to be at least give you an
option to say I want to be informed like
whatever styling is in my my container
in the shiny app this plotly graph
should should use inherit those Styles a
little bit better so I would like for
that to be be a feature someday for
sure awesome well thank you all so much
I will go through and just see which
questions we might have missed and send
them over to you if that's okay um to
make sure that we get to those too I did
notice that some people had given some
suggestions for topics they'd like to
cover in some of these sessions so I
just wanted to remind everybody that we
host these workflow demos the last
Wednesday of every month and the topics
that we cover come from suggestions that
we receive from you all as well so if
you want to later on comment in the
YouTube chat or just comment here now if
there's something that you'd like to see
please let us know we'd love to hear
from
you um maybe one other just quick
question too if people have further
questions about BSB or feedback or or
want to get involved with the package
like what's the best way to do
that you want to take this one gck sure
definitely through our our GitHub page
um you can search for our studio GitHub
on or sorry our studio BSB on GitHub and
uh we are we are always happy answer
questions in our issues um and to to you
know listen to feedback and to help
out Garrett Ryan anything else you want
to add
to I'm good I just want to say thank you
again to everyone for attending the
workshop and for those of you who saying
that was
beautiful I'm going to edit that part
out of the recording so nobody can
replay that
part um well thank you all so much for
joining us today I did just put the link
into the chat if you do want to join us
again we have these the last Wednesday
of every month that that link in the
chat will add them all to your calendar
but thank you so much for joining us
have a great rest of day everybody